TOTAL OF FIVE BILLS TODAY AND
WE NOTICED THAT ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM SO BE ACTING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE AND HAVE MEMBERS ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE. HERE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM. SO THEN
WILL BEGIN WITHOUT- THE AUTHORS
THAT ARE PRESENT AND THAT'S
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO WHICH IS
AB. FOUR ZERO SEVEN. FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS AND-
YEAH. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE ENTIRE- PRESENTATION
FOR THE DAY FOR ALL FIVE WE
HAVE. I RECOGNIZE AND
REPUBLICAN CONCURS. THANK THIS
SERVICE PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PRESENT WHENEVER READY. DOESN'T
THAT I'M SURE ONCE WE HAVE A
QUORUM MISTER CHAIR WILL
PROBABLY MOVE EACH OF THE BILLS
AB FOUR OH SEVEN WILL EXPAND
ACCESS QUALITY EYE CARE BY
AUTHORIZING OPTOMETRISTS TO
TREAT ADDITIONAL CONDITIONS OF
THE I. THAT IS WELL WITHIN
THEIR TRAINING. I SPECIFICALLY
THIS BILL UPDATES AND
CONSOLIDATES CURRENT LIST OF
CONDITIONS AN OPTOMETRIST IS
ABLE TO TREAT AND BY WHAT
METHODS ALLOWS LICENSED
OPTOMETRISTS PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
CLIA WAIVED TESTS FOR
CONDITIONS RELATED TO THE I.
AUTHORIZES TREATMENT UTILIZING
LIGHT THERAPY FOR DRY LIFE
PERMITS THE USE OF FDA APPROVED
MEDICATIONS AND LAWS UPTIME
MEASURES TO PROVIDE THE
COVERED. NINETEEN VACCINE
MEMBERS THIS IS A BILL THAT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS AT THE
FISHERMAN'S BEEN VERY HELPFUL
IN THIS PROCESS WILL AS WELL
THIS RESPECTFULLY. ASK WHEN I
VOTE WHEN THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU FOR MUCH
MISTER SALAS WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO. I
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OURS AND
THAT WE HAVE TWO THAT ARE
POTENTIALLY ON THE LINE AS WELL
LET'S SEE FIRST WE HAVE.
REGISTERED HERE WITH US IS. A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA OPTOMETRIC
ASSOCIATION PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PRESENT WHEN YOU'RE READY. HI
THIS IS CHRISTINE SCHULTZ
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
OPTOMETRIC ASSOCIATION WHERE
THE SPONSORS OF THE BEFORE
SEVEN. I LIKE TO THINK THE BILL
AUTHORED AND CO AUTHORED FOR
ALL THEIR WORK ALSO WANT TO
THANK BOTH HOUSES OF THE
LEGISLATURE FOR OVERSEEING THE
PROCESS. THIS BILL WAS THE
RESULT OF COLLABORATION WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF EYE PHYSICIANS AND
SURGEONS. WE DIDN'T HAVE TIME
TO ADDRESS ALL THE ISSUES THAT
THERE ARE STILL THINGS WE NEED
TO WORK ON NEXT YEAR BUT THIS
IS A GREAT BILL THAT CLEANS UP
THE STATUTE. AND MAKES THE
SCOPE OF PRACTICE FOR
OPTOMETRISTS IN ASSISTANCE
BETTER MATCH WHAT'S ACTUALLY
HAPPENING IN THE REAL WORLD.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE SHOW CINEMA MOVE ONTO. OUR
NEXT PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT
AND ASSEMBLY OF MISTER LANG OR
MISUSE. ARE EITHER ON OUR
PUBLIC LINE. K. HEARING NOTED
THERE- DEFINITIONAL PRIOR
WITNESS SUPPORT WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
WISH TO ALSO INDICATE THEIR
SUPPORT. YOU CAN OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. ELIZABETH IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
IT WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH THIS SHOW
LANG REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF EYE
PHYSICIANS AND SURGEONS I WOULD
GET- DID- WHAT- CHRISTINE SILVA
SAID FROM THE- OPTOMETRIST
ASSOCIATION A LOT OF HARD WORK
THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE STAFF
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFFS FOR.
THE WORK THAT'S DONE IN THIS
BILL AND WE SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
LANG. OPERATOR ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME. AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. IF YOU
WHO WAS SPEAKING OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO AT
THIS TIME. SMALL ALL TOGETHER
MY NUMBER. OKAY AND WE'LL WITH
LINE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES HI MY NAME IS. SURE NO
OPTION I'M WITH BUT YOU CAN
ALWAYS AND I AM CALLING BECAUSE
I OPPOSE STRONGLY OPPOSE ANY
BILL THAT- FORCES ANYBODY FOR
MATH OR- FOR TAXIS ON TO
PEOPLE. SO STRONGLY STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU. I
MISSED HERE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND SEE AN
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM AT THIS TIME WILL MOVE THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS BEFORE DO THAT. WE
WILL CALL ROLE. NOT BE HERE.
FOR BERMAN YOUR LINK HERE TEN
YEAR TO. CUNNINGHAM TELL ME
YOUR FONG GIPSON YEAH ISN'T
THERE HOLDEN. IRWIN MCCARTY.
MEDINA YOUR. ONE SALAS PRESENT
THANK WEBER. GIVE ESTABLISH A
CORE AND- IN ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CAN YOU
MEMBERS SEEING THEM THE SUMMER
SOLSTICE WAS TO CLOSE THAT WITH
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION THE
OPPOSITION I CALLED IN WAS
OBVIOUSLY CALLING ON A
DIFFERENT MATTER. CREATE AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- IS A MOTION BY MISTER
GRAYSON SAID BY MR FLOOR FROM
THE SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE RECOMMENDATION IS THAT THE
SENATE AMENDMENT SPEAKING
CARDIN'S LOW. HI HELLO HI FLORA
FLORA HI BERMAN BERMAN HI BLOOM
BLOOM I TEN TEN I'D TO. HAM
DALLI DALLI AYE FONG FONG AYE
GIPSON GIPSON HI GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
IRWIN IRWIN AYE MCCARTY. DANA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN SALAS HI
SALAS I ATTAIN WEBER. FIFTEEN
VOTES BUT IT COULD MEAN
THIRTEEN VOTES WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WILL MOVE BACK AND
FOLLOW ORDER. FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE THIS IS AB EIGHT THIRTY
AGAIN THIS HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION POSADA. BUT SO
FAR WHENEVER READY THE MESSAGE
CARE ACT. GOOD MAN THIS. YES
FOR OPENING UP- PUBLIC
TESTIMONY WILL BEGIN FOR HERE
IN THE CHAMBERS FILL FREE TO
COME UP TO THE MIKE FROM
WHATEVER READY. THE BILL MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS SORRY MISTER
CHAIRMAN CHRIS MAKAYLA ON
BEHALF OF S. C. I. CALIFORNIA
FUNERAL SERVICES WE APPRECIATE
LANGUAGE IN THERE THAT'LL HELP
TO RESOLVE AN ISSUE WITH D. C.
A. R. REGULATORS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEE NO
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK. IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS OPERATOR WOULD YOU
KINDLY OPEN UP THE LINES. FOR
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IT. AB EIGHT
THIRTY PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. JUST MELLOW
GATHERED LINE NUMBER. AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING ANNA BACK ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SEEN OR DIGITAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AND AT
THE BACK TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE UNSEEN NOTATIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THIS
ALREADY BEEN IN MOTION AND A
SECOND COMMITTEE SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE
RECOMMENDATION IS THAT THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS TO BE
CONCURRED AND LOW HI. WELL I
FLORIDA. FLORIDA BERMAN. BERMAN
I BLOOM. BLOOM I TEN TEN I TO.
CUNNINGHAM DALLI DALLI AYE FONG
FINITE. GIPSON AYE GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
IRWIN IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN. SALAS SALAS I ATTAIN
WEBER. FOURTEEN FOURTEEN VOTES
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS. KARGIL MOVE
ON THEN TO FILES ITEM THREE
FOUR AND FIVE AND I'LL PASS THE
GAVEL OVER TO OUR VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WILL
START WITH A BRIEF. THIRTY ON
THE STATE BOARD OF TOM. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR VOTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WELL NUMBER TO
WIN THIS IS IN THE CHAMBER SEEN
THE WITNESSES THE CHAMBER.
MISTER MODERATORS ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES. WHICH SPEED ON AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE NO ONE IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. OKAY. ARE THERE ANY KEY
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE LINE WAS
MODERATOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE. SEEING NONE MISTER GEORGE
CLOSE. I STRICTLY ESTERBROOK
SCHOOL WITH A LOT. THE
RECOMMENDATION IS THAT THE
SENTIMENT BE CONCURRED IN LOW.
HI MY AYE FLORA AYE FOREIGN AYE
BERMAN BERMAN I BLOOM. BLOOM I
TEN TEN I TO. CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. DOWN DOWN THE
IPHONE. FONG I GIPSON FIVE
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN IRWIN
AND MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN. SALAS SALAS
I ATTAIN WEBER. FIFTY THE BILL
THAT WITH FIFTEEN LEAVE IT OPEN.
ALL RIGHT. WE WANT TO AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY FIVE CLARK THIS
IS A SERIOUS THE NEXT SERIES OF
OUR SENSE OF BILLS AND THIS IS
THE CALIFORNIA VETERINARY
MEDICAL BOARD AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK PRIVATE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MEMBERS. MISS MODERATE
EQUIVALENT OF THAT THE KEY
WITNESSES ON THE BOTTOM LINE
PLEASE. THE MORNING CARE AND
MEMBERS OF DEPUTY DOMINICAN BOX
THERE THE BATTERY MEDICAL BOARD
AND SUPPORT HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OR OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
LINES. WE DO HAVE LINE TWENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AGRIMENSOR
CAROLINE BURKE THIS IS KAREN
LAYING ON TOP OF THE CALIFORNIA
ANIMAL WELFARE ASSOCIATION
ALONG WITH THE ROLE- COUNTY
SUPERVISORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
MYSELF. HER- WE'VE WAITED
APPRECIATED SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. MR WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEE NOTE OF
WITNESSES IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
FOR BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THE QUESTION COMMITTEE CNN'S
JOE WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ABOUT
THANK YOU SECURE PLEASE FOLLOW
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT SENATE
AMENDMENTS TO BE CONCURRED IN
LOW HI WELL I FLOOR. FLOOR AYE
BERMAN BERMAN I BLOOM. M. I.
TEND. TEN I TO CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. DALLY DALLY
IPHONE FROM AYE GIPSON HI
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON AYE GRAYSON
AYE. MCCARTY AYE MEDINA MEDINA
AYE MULLIN SALAS SALAS I TEN
WEBER. BILLS OVER THIRTY WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN AND WILL BE DOWN
TO FIFTEEN AB FIFTEEN THIRTY
SIX MR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
COLLEAGUES I HOPE AS WE
DISCUSSED THIS BILL THAT YOU'LL
TAKE ON THE- TAKEN THE OPULENCE
OF THIS ROOM AS THIS MIGHT BE
THE LAST TIME WILL BE IN THIS
ROOM GIVEN THE BE MOVING TO A
NEW BUILDING. BECAUSE THIS IS
THE BORDER VOCATIONAL NURSING
AND PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
MISTER MODERATORS ANY WITNESSES
OR KEEP WHEN THIS IS ON THE
PHONE LINE AND SUPPORT. SMALL
WILL GATHER ONE NUMBER. WHY
NEVER TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS KOBE
PRESIDING WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS- WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE- SINCE THAT REVIEW FOR
THE BBMP T. V.'S ESTABLISHED IN
THIS BILL OR ABOUT TWENTY YEARS
IN THE MAKING AND WILL HELP
ADDRESS THE BACKLOG. OF SCHOOLS
THAT ARE APT APPLIED FOR
ACCREDITATION- SO WE SUPPORT
THE CURRENTS AND SENTIMENTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE
SUPPORT OP TO A. FIFTY THIRTY
SIX. IN THIS CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BRING ABOUT
TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM SCENE NO
WITNESSES IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. A QUESTION
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEEN NONE OF
WHICH I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
ESPECIALLY ESCRIBIR THANK YOU
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
SENATE MEMBERS BECOME PART IN
LOW. HIGH LOW HIGH FLOOR. FOR
AYE BERMAN. BERMAN I BLOOM. AYE
BLOOM AYE CHAN CHAN I TO.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I DOWNEY.
DOWNEY I FONG AM I GIPSON
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN- WHEN I
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE MEDINA AND
I'M MEDINA AYE MULLIN SALAS
FIREFIGHTING TEN AYE WEBER. OR
YOUR- BILL THAT WAS OF THE
BELIEVE IT OPEN FOR A FEW
MINUTES. YEAH I SAW.
RIGHT. TO
EXATING I WEBER IRAQ. AB
FIFTEEN FOR RECOMMENDATION IS
THAT IS THAT I'M I'M SPEAKING
CARTON TO MON THANK TEN AYE
WEBER. IRAQ AB FEB THIRTY FIVE
RECOGNIZE AS AN KERR INTO MINE
TEN THING I'D LOVE IRAQ. ONE AB
THIRTY THIRTY FIVE SIX THREE IS
CINNAMON TAKING PART IN TWO
MINE HIGHER TEAM OVER THE.